hey guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
crazy
crazy
[Music]
here we are once again and
let's just first before we get into
everything just promote the dates
phoenix i opened up a whole nother show
phoenix it's all [ __ ] it's all said
and done
the boy went bonkers nutty filling up
some seats on the first show at the
celebrity theater so he added another
show
the good seats may not still be
available now that this [ __ ] already
sits up since i recorded it but it's all
it's available right now go to
crystallia.com and come on phoenix come
see your boy
don't push me come see your boy at the
celebrity theater fill up those second
that second show on get those butts on
them say something god damn it
but yeah dude he's johnny fills him up
sounds sexual all good but it's not a
mint seat so we did that i got the oops
merch is live right now and the don't
push me merch man show up to my shows
wearing the [ __ ] we got shows in irvine
coming up this weekend but it's all sold
out can't get tickets anymore see in
phoenix but show up to phoenix but most
importantly
show up to everyone else's shows to
other comedians in my merch because
that's how we let them know that these
babies are still alive my baby oh god
but for real though so that's what's up
subscribe and uh like the chat like the
channel dude it really helps make
friends in the comments let's try to get
them comments up and activate that
algorithm baby dude i'll tell you what
right now before i uh took this uh
before i took this [ __ ] uh before i'm
over here taking this [ __ ] show for a
jog that's what i'm saying before i'm up
here taking this episode for a [ __ ]
brisk walk
i [ __ ] cut my [ __ ] i got another
beard trimmer because what happens is
they keep breaking if you don't have a
beard trimmer that keeps breaking you
ain't really trimming your beard now are
you so i did it and now there's a piece
of hair right here somewhere and it
keeps poking me in the collarbone ah yes
dude is it the most annoying thing yes
dude but do we keep rolling we do but
it's so [ __ ] annoying because it's
basically just like this is what it's
doing the whole time
the whole time i can't figure out where
it is and it's pissing me off yes dude
here's a here's a hair but did i get it
i got it but that's probably not the
right one ah
yes dude constant annoyance you have to
when you shave when you cut when you
trim your [ __ ] you got to go directly
into the i don't know if chicks know
this i don't know if women know this as
a man when you cut your beard what you
got to do immediately after that is dive
into a pool otherwise you're [ __ ] dude
hairs are everywhere all the time all in
your neck
i mean yeah it kind of happens when you
get your hair cut when you sit in that
chair and you get the hair cut
but
mostly what it does
mostly what happens is when you cut your
beard you got to take a shower
immediately right after or dive into a
river you got to sit you know what you
got to do okay you got to get under a
waterfall and just [ __ ] let it
cascade all over your [ __ ] where it
glistens over your chest and [ __ ]
you know over those [ __ ]
over that washboard tommy because we all
have those
but yeah dude uh we're here and we're
doing it and uh we got that [ __ ] another
with chris episode is up hiking it's
[ __ ] doing stupid number it's dude
it's doing [ __ ] stupid numbies dude
so anyway
we do stupid numbies that's what we do
here um so you activate that algorithm
and help out and like just destroy that
[ __ ] one and dine that like button
you know what i mean but whatever dude
um i did i cut my beard and a little bit
and uh you know i don't know what length
to keep it you know i didn't realize
during the pandemic i let it grow really
really long and the kind of that became
the thing and then i saw a picture of me
like three years ago and i kept it kind
of cool i kept it kind of like clean
there i just kept it like peeking out
like the second day of chia pet like i
kind of just kept it like a little bit
peeking out like all my hairs and my
cheeks were doing it like without like
opening a door like what's going on like
that's how it was like did so did i hear
something like that's how my my hair was
coming out and then
during the pandemic i just kind of let
it just grow
and uh now this is kind of the style but
it's getting real gray dude i know your
boy's young as [ __ ] but it's getting
real gray oh and it was my birthday i'm
42 now and it was also april uh first
that it was april fools uh and everyone
thinks that my new podcast with my
brother coming out called lifeline is an
april fool's joke but it's not an april
fool's joke it's a real podcast called
lifeline with my brother matalia so go
to the lifeline over there and like and
subscribe and be ready for that [ __ ] to
drop enough with the promo though dude i
don't even mean to be doing promos it's
just i got a lot of stuff going on in my
in my life and i need to promo it i
guess right like i told you i did the
[ __ ] the with chris stuff the new
lifeline i cut my beard this is all
promo [ __ ]
but um
yeah and now we're just chilling
and
we are just chilling
saw a dude the other day at a coffee
shop that i haven't seen
i tell you what i think it you get to 30
late 30s is when if you've been in the
same place like this geographically in
the same place in your late 30s
uh
and you're in your late 30s what happens
is
it's very weird in your late 20s and
even in your early 30s if you see
somebody
if you see somebody and you hang out
with them for like a year or something
and then you see them 10 years later
they look roughly the same but when you
start seeing people 20 years later they
start looking like [ __ ] old
renditions of themselves and old
versions of themselves and that's what's
crazy
like i saw i used to you know i used to
set up shop at this [ __ ] coffee bean
when i used to run that block over on
ventura and coldwater now i don't go
there anymore what happened is the
[ __ ] place shut down and everybody
that i used to see at that coffee shop
dispersed into different coffee shops
you know some of them go to the cold
water coffee bean on whitsett some of
them go to [ __ ] aroma cafe some of
them go over to the coffee fix some of
them go over to one over on sunset i
mean these guys are out there we're out
there right we're out there we're all
out there
it's like we went through some [ __ ] it's
like uh the movie stand by me and we all
got together later on
right or it you know
nothing really horrific happened except
for the coffee bean shut down but
we all see each other now and i see
these guys and i see them 20 years later
it is insane to see these dudes 20 years
later because that's when you realize
life just keeps going unless you die
right life just keeps going if you don't
get cancer or get hit by a bus or suffer
a heart attack or you're too fat and
[ __ ] basically just choke on yourself
life just keeps going
and you get to see people and the only
thing that remains the same are
basically their eyes right
because i don't like to say this and i
don't say this
but the eyes are the windows to the soul
right
that's not something that i say a lot
you know we keep it light hearted and
joking in this congratulations podcast
but lest we forget eyes
they're the windows to the soul
you know so it doesn't matter how old or
how fat or skinny
you know hair losing people get
less we forget the eyes they're the
windows to the soul and when these guys
see when i see them in a new coffee shop
because this is where i always see them
in a new coffee shop that i happen to
roll into and i'm a medullo of course
but then these guys come in and they
look like fat old versions of themselves
but then i see their eyes and i'm like
oh
20 years later but
lest we forget eyes are the windows to
the soul
and i wonder what the [ __ ] they've been
up to because i forget about these
[ __ ] until i see him what has
this dude been doing for 20 years
isn't that [ __ ] crazy
it's a reminder that life keeps going
and
you got to just kind of
i don't know it made me feel some sort
of poignant like thing because i'm like
well life keeps going but you kind of
got to just kind of keep being true to
yourself and keep doing your [ __ ] you
know all these dudes i just see them at
coffee shops but you got to just keep
doing you and if doing you is going and
being happy getting that [ __ ] coffee
two years later at a new place because
the other place [ __ ] went under then
that's what you got to do so props to
those dudes out there you know who you
are i don't know if you listen to my pi
i didn't have this podcast back then
when i did the [ __ ] first coffee bean
but it was wild to see these dudes over
when you get like you're listening now
if you're in your 20s or something just
remember i said this when you're 42 and
you see the same person it's wild dude
it's really wild people just keep living
it makes me think about maybe we're in
the metaverse almost dropped that
[ __ ] coffee right there
and we've been in the metaverse for way
longer than we thought but i saw a
batman dude
i saw batman
i was gonna do it on my review mode in
my uh in my um what do you call it on my
other i'm a patreon [ __ ] cause i do that
segment review mode on my patreon
uh but yeah man i saw batman
and guess what dude
and this is a fact it's the best batman
ever
it's the best batman that's ever been
dude including all of them yay
including all of them including all of
them
including all of them
so stop right there some people are
pissed right now well actually you know
okay that makes me laugh because the
dark knight is the thing that set it up
and you know what if
it wasn't for the dark knight a lot of
these superhero movies wouldn't exist
but i'm gonna stop you right there you
[ __ ] dork cause this one's the best
one
yay
[Laughter]
why because of everything
because of everything except catwoman
because of everything let me tell you
right now if catwoman is in a batman
movie that's a mistake catwoman is the
[ __ ] worst superhero it's what you
know why what does she do
i'm waiting
what does she do
hey go ahead explain explain to me
driving in your car or in your cubicle
or on your jog take a hot second stop
jogging relax and say out loud to me
because we're talking this is a
conversation what does catwoman do
i'm waiting
go ahead oh oh oh what'd she do
backflips
what'd she do avoid [ __ ]
what what what did she do
what did she ever do what did that movie
with [ __ ] halle berry do i'd rather
go see that [ __ ] stupid movie with
francis mcdormand where she's just
chilling outside that came out last year
it's so boring dude
catwoman is the most
boring
character there has ever been except for
every frances mcdormand character
okay
also
the e this is the thing that is awesome
about this batman and you agree dude
okay
here we go
this is the thing that's awesome about
this batman is that christopher nolan
who's great okay who's great yes of
course he makes confusing movies like
tenon and yes of course he makes crazy
movies like interstellar very confusing
was it good it was just a lot if anybody
says anything about interstellar besides
wow that movie was a lot
then they're bullshitting you know what
i mean
they're just bullshitting okay
but here's why batman chris nolan okay
so he kind of so he came out with the
first batman movie which was everyone
was like whoa and it was after chris
christian bale made the machinist and he
was like 14 pounds now all of a sudden
he's beefed up being batman and
christian bale was a great batman i
can't argue that he's the first guy who
kind of changed his voice and you kind
of were like okay i could see how people
don't know this is bruce wayne because
he kind of seems like a [ __ ]
different super different person in this
thing he's talking differently right
he's not being michael keaton or adam
west where he's just like hey how's it
going you're like oh you're just the guy
you're bruce wayne right
but now
the [ __ ] first one comes in and the
the first movie uh that he made which
was batman begins right which was cool
okay batman begins fine
there was too much non-batman [ __ ] in it
i thought like if you're gonna make a
movie about batman make a movie where
he's kicking ass immediately i don't
need to see like
him in his study what should i do and
then a bat flies through the window and
he's like huh that would be a good like
i don't need to see all the origin i
don't need to see his parents die
like when he was six
start the ass kicking from
jump
first scene should be just
and he's
getting
[ __ ] and just knocking [ __ ] out
do you know what i'm talking about
dude from jump dude don't even start
with the credits i don't give a [ __ ] who
made it just from jump just [ __ ] yeah
[Applause]
just flying from building to build that
kicking a guy with a mask that's what we
need immediately stopping crooks
all right
so batman begins
no thank you now dark knight was it a
cultural phenomenon yes you could argue
that did it pave the way for this
realism in superhero hero movies that
for some people for some reason people
gravitate towards even those superheroes
are [ __ ] ridiculous
yes it did okay
but did it
now would this new batman exist if the
other if the other chris miller movies
if they didn't if they weren't made i
don't know but i don't give a [ __ ] right
like people say richard pryor was the
goat okay and now they say dave
chappelle's the goat and people say well
would richard pryor did richard bryan
pay the way for dave chappelle yeah but
i don't give a [ __ ] dave chappelle if
he's the goat he's the goat i don't give
a [ __ ] i'm not that kind of guy where
it's like you got to pay homage to the
other [ __ ] dude everything
sucks after 20 years anyway you ever
seen [ __ ] laurel and hardy
how hilarious is it them trying to get
that piano up those stairs okay
no disrespect right
but my point is i saw this new batman
and they rooted it in reality okay i
mean the riddler isn't even like
laughing or doing riddler [ __ ] he's just
completely in like and i know what you
did last summer
green kind of raincoat
so it's way different
but there was it was in this world where
you bought the cinematography was
beautiful now robert pattinson who i'm a
huge fan of
he's a little thin right
and i'm like this is going to be vampire
batman
but it wasn't though he played an emo
batman and they didn't really show him
too much as bruce wayne which was good
because i don't know if i necessarily
buy him as this charismatic bruce wayne
but what the movie did was tonally they
accepted it and we accepted it totally
they made him batman and he barely saw
the light in the day right there's that
one scene where he [ __ ] where he
wakes where he's having a meeting and
he's just like this
robert patton and rob pattinson doing
that smart acting just kind of like ah
but the sunlight you know he does this
crazy cool subtle acting where he's just
like ah that's that's the kind of acting
i do where i'm just like oh the sunlight
you know
because we both do smart acting but
so
it was gr he was great
batman was great the guy nailed that the
cinematography was beautiful which i
don't even really give a [ __ ] about make
the story good but all of the rules that
they set up
adhered to all of the rules that they
set up the only thing that happened that
was kind of jerky was when he hit the
nitro boost and the car [ __ ]
ramped up over the thing and then the
penguin
thought he had him and then the [ __ ]
whole thing exploded and then batman
came out victorious which you know
whatever you got to have one of those
things but even when he pulled that
[ __ ] zip line when he jumped off the
building pulled that zip line and was
the bat guy you know and and [ __ ] was
flying and even though he would have
died doing that i kind of bought it
because it was like all clunky and [ __ ]
and here's why it's the best batman
because
my friends are like it's not better than
dark knight so then i went back and i
watched dark knight
because that's what i do why because i
have ocd why because i'm an addict why
because once i have something in my head
i can't let it go i watch one batman i
don't watch one batman oh dude picture
me watching one batman
i watch all of them
so i went directly home i started
watching the dark knight
and i'm not even going to tell you the
new batman
isn't it's not that the new batman is
better than the dark knight i'm here to
tell you that the dark knight
is just
good and watchable and if you say it's
great
you'll have a [ __ ] very fierce
argument on your hands if you're with me
okay
because in the first scene
in the second scene the first scene is
the joker thing which is like okay it's
rooted in realism right these are bank
robbers trying to rob a bank this isn't
guys jumping off buildings and [ __ ]
shooting flames or webs out of their
[ __ ] actually that's even doable i guess
but
nobody's flying right and then batman
come comes in after these mock batman
guys try to ra save the day with guns
and batman comes in grabs someone's gun
on the end of the gun and [ __ ]
bends the gun dude
is this rooted in realism or not
dude you can't have something
adhering
to the roots of realism
and then a [ __ ] crook comes by with a
rifle and batman goes gunk
first of all it's irresponsible right
get the guy
if this is real he might shoot your
[ __ ] face off so don't just grab the
[ __ ] and bend it get the guy right
you didn't do that so then you go to
bend the nozzle so you go to bend the
[ __ ] nozzle so what would happen
right the guy would let go of the gun
number one number two the guy is 180
pounds he
he would be fighting back
also you can't bend steel
so right at that moment i'm out
i'm out
you can't bend steel in the real world
with your hand so i'm out and then i saw
batman
guess where a car would be jump down
flights of [ __ ] stairs
uh or levels of of of uh what's the
[ __ ] uh park lot and just crash onto
the [ __ ] car
and get the scarecrow and i'm out dude
and then there's a scene where uh what's
his name uh from
aaron eckhart is harvey dent
and he like a guy pulls a gun on him in
the [ __ ] witness booth and then he he
saves the day he grabs the gun and i'm
like what rooted in realism dude [ __ ]
all that man the movie's just good this
new batman reigns supreme it's the best
batman and [ __ ] yes christian bell
was a great batman but dude this dude
nailed it robert pattons and nailed it
catwoman see you later never put
catwoman in any movie ever she sucks
dude it just the character sucks and the
actress did it fine but everyone else
nailed it do it colin farrell where was
he
oh he was in the movie where oh he was
the penguin stop lying that didn't look
like him or sound like him that's some
[ __ ] good acting and i won't say
masterful acting like my friend dan did
because that's [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
everyone always says stuff with the arts
is masterful but it's like you're really
just [ __ ]
you know
you
talk about other things that's masterful
like like brain surgery not not art
because that's just
this review is devolving but it's the
best batman dude i spent entirely too
much time talking about this batman but
it's so good
[Music]
merch is off to a good start this year
thanks to
ship station
with ship station you'll never worry
about shipping again make this switch to
a solution that handles all your
shipping needs quickly affordably and
painlessly take it from me shipstation
is already trusted by over 100 000
e-commerce sellers uh keep track of
orders from any sales channel
easily find the best shipping carrier
with deeply discounted rates uh and
automate just about any shipping task
with just a few clicks uh my favorite
thing about shipstation honestly is the
fact that all of the fans that uh get
the merch they get it fast and they get
it hassle-free um it's really awesome i
get a lot of really cool notes about
that and that's all thanks to uh
shipstation save time by funneling all
your orders into one simple interface no
matter what you're selling it's very
simple save money
uh when you compare carrier options and
choose the best shipping solution every
time
shipstation works with every carrier so
you can always find the best fit for you
your small business can access the same
discounted rates
usually reserved for fortune 500
companies so
that's cool isn't it yeah okay so get
with shipstation uh you also could shave
save your sanity um knowing that it's
just being handled and taken care of and
that you're getting the best uh rates
um they do it all so it's kind of no
wonder why not 98 of companies that use
shipstation for a year keep using it for
as long as they're in business
okay it's that good ship more in less
time with shipstation use my offer code
congrats to get a 60 day free trial
that's two months free of no hassle you
like free right it's stress free
shipping all right so go to
shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in congrats ship
station make ship happen
[Music]
it really is good i was at the imp
i was at the improv the other night and
i was doing a show with theo and uh
i don't remember who else was on the
show but theo was there and uh this guy
theo goes on and gets off and i'm on in
a little bit
and this guy says hey to theo he says
hey
you wanna
this is what he says hey you want a
bullet
and i'm like here we go another lunatic
dude
here we go
just another lunatic
i can't dude
everybody's so crazy
i can't
i'm tired of it
be crazy to
the people in your lives
don't make me deal with it
i'm chilling having a conversation with
theo one of my friends and some guy
walks up and says to theo hey man
big fan
want a bullet
and theo said
is that
drugs and the guy said
no and pulls out
a bullet
and theo's like oh cool man takes the
bullet and then i kind of step away a
little bit
and why do i step away
because weirdness
cause this bullet holder
is
polluting my area
hey guy with a bad brain
don't pollute my area
step away
and fix your organ in your head
okay
hey guy
don't bring a bullet or anything over in
my area
i didn't know you
and now i do
and this
wholeheartedly sucks for me
okay
so now i'm dealing with it but i'm not
really am i because he gave the bullet
to theo now did it offend me in a weird
part of my brain yes because why didn't
i get the bullet but i step away and i'm
like you know what i did
i avoided a bullet
literally
right i dodged a bullet
so he gives it to theo and then i see
this guy just
that that that to theo and i'm like [ __ ]
yeah dude hell yeah that's when it's
good that someone else is a fan of
someone else and not me because this guy
is just
that to the rat king yeah
that that and i'm standing over there
just counting my blessings and right now
it's one
i don't have to deal with this [ __ ]
guy
so then
i'm there for about three minutes
talking to someone
else and then theo says yeah man i don't
know and leaves
to the guy and then the guy
comes over to me
with all of his weirdness
and he's being
actually weirder and you know what he's
doing
just
shuffling around
it's not like he's like
being
overtly weird he's being covertly weird
like
he's dealing with something internally
and also wants to talk about it but
guess what he wants to talk about it to
me and guess what i'm not that guy
because you already polluted one area
and i moved over to another area and
gentrified it right
so let's back up
and not pollute my new neighborhood
okay
so he comes over
and he says now theo's already gone and
he says
that was weird okay well that was weird
so now i'm stuck
because i know theo and i know theo is
weird but i also know very little bit
about this new guy but he's also weird
and also i don't know him so
don't be weird have that thing when you
meet somebody and you want to make a
good impression don't you you all i'm
thinking of when i meet people is well i
hope that they don't [ __ ] think i'm
weird
so this guy already [ __ ] it up for
theo and i all right so theo walks away
he said well that was weird well that's
[ __ ] weird oh that's weird
and uh he wants me so badly to say like
oh what happened
but check it out i don't know you dude
and i just gentrified this whole area of
this hallway
okay
so he says to me uh well that was weird
again
and it was like i used to have this
roommate where this guy would like i did
i used to have this roommate like when i
was in my 20s and he would be in his
room and he would just be like
i would be chilling during my day and we
weren't really friends but we were
friendly you know his roommates and he
would just do [ __ ] like
uh
he would be like huh
and and and i wouldn't say anything on
purpose because he wanted so badly to
just
have a conversation and does that make
me a dick but he would just be on his
computer and be like huh
i'd hear through the walls
well that's weird
[Laughter]
and like because a few times i'd beat my
head in i'd be like what's up and you'd
be like no it's just crazy because this
thing was and i'm i'm oh oh oh
you know when you realize it's
absolutely nothing you just wanted oh
you wanted a connection dude ah [ __ ] i
got had
so this guy's doing that well that's
he's now a new version of my roommate
and he's like well that's weird i'm like
oh yeah i gotta go and i go and i leave
and then
later
i avoid this
but he comes up to me
and he's like
hey man
uh
i'm a huge fan
and i said oh thanks and he says
uh oh this is what happened so he [ __ ] i
told yeah okay i got this out order so
so then he's in the hall we're in the
hallway later [ __ ] god damn it i forgot
about this and this girl comes up to me
and she says hey can i get a picture and
i'm like yeah and she's like sorry i
know this is like the weirdest thing
ever to happen to you
so now this whole thing is just a mess
right so now i got to be like
now she put me in a position where i
either need to be like yeah oh yeah
but it's all good but i don't do that
because i keep it real right so i say to
him i say to her i said
listen
you i this is not weird at all
i've dealt with things that are
way weirder than this and people who are
way weirder because i don't want her to
get the credit for being the weirdest
thing that happened to me all day now am
i mini-minded yes but that's what i did
okay
i needed her to not get the credit for
being the weirdest thing that happened
to me all day all right
mini minded sure but also
had to let her know because i'm petty
okay and so now she says can i get a
picture and i say yeah sure so we get a
picture and her boyfriend takes it and
then she walks away and then he the the
bullet giver to theo walks up to me and
says hey
uh how about uh how about that and i
said
what
and he said
how weird was that
and i'm like is there a dick on my head
or something i don't understand what's
weird right now except for the people
being weird dude
hey this is weird no dude it's you
like you can't walk up to someone and be
like ah isn't this all weird
it's [ __ ] you dude
i'm not oh that was when when the person
says well that was awkward yeah cause
you made it awkward
you don't get to i don't feel awkward
i'm [ __ ]
stonewalled awareness dude
i'm a [ __ ] stone wall
i got bulletproof glass to prevent weird
feelings on me man
i've dealt with all of the weirdness man
and so you can't so then this guy so now
this girl i know this is the weirdest
thing but can i have a picture i know
it's so weird i said no i've dealt with
such weird [ __ ]
a guy tried to hand a bullet to one of
my best friends or five minutes ago
so then she leaves and i say hey no
problem at all now i know i'm [ __ ] in a
moment about this but please don't come
for me man i mean come for me if you
want but it's so annoying when people
are like wow chris is really a dick dude
you don't get my humor leave it at that
i was genuinely nice to these
[ __ ] so leave it at that you
don't get my computer my computer even
though i meant to say humor leave it at
that dude all right so now she walks
away and the bullet giver the [ __ ]
theo says hey wasn't that uh hey hey
that's crazy and i'm like what's what's
crazy man and he says well it's um
so
that girl just asked you for a picture
and i said oh yeah yeah and he said well
what about uh
her her boyfriend was right there and i
said uh-huh and he said
so she just asked for a picture and her
boyfriend was there and i said
yeah
and he said
huh
how do you deal with that
and i said
you just saw how i deal with that
and he goes
huh
and then we walked away
i think people just want to have like a
moment with somebody that they like are
a fan of which is cool
but then i walked over to theo and i was
like what's up with that bullet guy and
he was like yeah man he was really
[ __ ] weird
and then i was like man we all got our
weird [ __ ] you know
theo uh is weird and i'm weird and that
dude is weird and we all kind of met a
meeting of the minds it was like the
weird avengers
and uh we didn't save any days we were
just weird uh but whatever dude i talked
way too long about that story and uh but
that's what happened and it's like just
if you want to go up to somebody and
have a nice little moment just like it's
the best when somebody just comes up and
say hey man i love what you do like and
if you want to tell a little story or
whatever i was with my friend the other
day and we were listening it was that's
great dude that's [ __ ] great
uh but yeah the weirdness dude we gotta
how about the [ __ ] um
[Music]
the uh
who that guy died from the uh foo
fighters he was 50. dude it's so weird
being 42 and seeing a 50 year old die i
don't even know how he died what just
drugs so sad
that's so [ __ ] [ __ ] up and sad
um
and then you see everybody's like posts
with like them and them if
the only way to honor somebody like that
a celebrity it's so
self-centered these [ __ ] i don't ever
i never post about anybody that dies
because it i find it so
self-centered
with these celebrities doing it like i
saw people posting
with bruce willis because he has
dementia and it's just like
and they were like i hope that bruce
sees this and it's like bruce can't read
okay that's the whole thing about this
brain thing and people are just like
yeah i met him yada yada it's like dude
oh you oh so you know bruce okay cool
it's so annoying when celebrities do
this and they it it's one thing when
they die but like this guy died and then
everyone's like oh we lost a good one
today here's us at [ __ ] mcdonald's
and it's just like
it's so like when i and here's the thing
too when i die and these people these
cucks too these people who [ __ ]
[ __ ] on me when i went through my
[ __ ] they'll post the pictures too [ __ ]
them [ __ ] dude
talk [ __ ] about me when i die
if you talk [ __ ] when i live talk [ __ ]
when i die don't come back and be like a
flawed man but we all love them eat my
[ __ ] dick dude
don't even post a picture of me when i
die post a picture of [ __ ]
you know
when i die post a picture of liam neeson
dude and just be like man this guy's
movies rip huh that's it dude
it's so annoying when these celebrities
do this [ __ ]
oh man devastated to hear the news be
devastated at home off the [ __ ]
internet i know we all grieve in our own
way but you don't know these
[ __ ] you met him once in the
popeyes
um
also are we done with kovid man like
it's like i haven't heard anyone get it
since the [ __ ] queen of england
and i still gotta ask for napkins at
cafes like have them out
nobody's getting covered because
you touch something that's something
else with nobody even has coveted
anymore
and then somebody is like i got to go to
coffee shops and i'm like can i get can
i get it they don't have the thing
anymore to get the napkins from you got
to ask from behind the thing because
they think it's safe dude you're fine
we're fine we're fine take your [ __ ]
mask off we're fine it's so annoying
that i gotta be there and i gotta ask
for extra dude put it out
you want to wear a mask on your own time
wear a mask on your own time but don't
you know put the napkins out
and then whenever you ask for napkin to
give you one napkin like i need more
dude you see you know
um
[Music]
i uh
i gotta see morbius is the main thing
i'm trying to say like i gotta see
morbius
a hundred percent
have to see morbius because the guy
who's in it is j no we don't say his
name here because he tried to have a
[ __ ] cult and thwart my call but he
can't thwart my call but we don't say
his name but he's nameless here but
[ __ ] jared leto you know i'm talking
about but we don't [ __ ] say his name
and he's good
i mean the guy's a good actor and he's
15 he looks like he's 25 and yeah we
don't [ __ ] say his name but yes of
course i'm talking about jared leto but
like dude he's a weird [ __ ] guy and
that's why he's a good actor because you
have to be super weird to be a good
actor you know otherwise you're just
like the rock and you're just saying the
lines
but he played morbius and i found out
the name in the [ __ ] his name is
michael morbius dude which is like
dude that's so
[Laughter]
[ __ ] stupid
hi michael morbius imagine you met a
dude named michael morby that should be
the [ __ ] like dude i'm barely on
board with peter parker by the way the
alliterations gotta go and i know they
made this [ __ ] when the [ __ ] stuff
was so corny anyway like back in the 40s
or whatever
like batman was like it pretty much
superman was gay as [ __ ] and it was but
but he was supposed to not be gay like
it's fine to be gay but superman was
supposed to not be gay but also he was
so gay
you know even in the 80s they did it
with he-man but like yo you gotta rename
the guy michael morbius
you gotta rename him it's 2022.
at least name him jeff morbius
also
make it so his last name
isn't morbius
that's so
[ __ ] dumb
because guess what if superheroes
existed and then i met a guy named
michael morbius
it's him
he blew your secret identity
change
e name
dude
michael morbius
like i get it clark kent okay peter
parker alliteration but all right
michael
morbius
dude
that's
[ __ ] horrible change it
and change it now it's 2022.
and yeah the movie sucks it's got 17 on
rotten tomatoes no [ __ ] it sucks
the reason why
michael
morbius dude hi i'm dr morbius oh it's
you
oh you're the vampire that
that is the anti-hero
it's like we don't live in the [ __ ]
year 1800 anymore where nobody would
know
jekyll and hot dude it says in the name
dude
it's like if the [ __ ] super it might
as the superheroes they might as well be
superhero mix saves the day
or doctor cleans the world up
[Laughter]
his name is michael morvius and i put it
on tick-tock and all i said was michael
morbius and i was laughing because when
i was when i figured it out his name was
michael morby
and dude people under the comments were
like sorry dude swinging a miss hey dude
i don't get it where's the joke okay
then you don't get it and i feel bad for
you because i tell you right now there
is nothing funnier than
the fact that in
2022
they made that marvel's doing so well
that they had to go to all the [ __ ]
characters and make a movie of morbius
and they didn't change the name michael
movies because they have to stay true to
it so the [ __ ] dorks will be like
well actually his name you should they
got to stay true because the movie will
get dragged in the movies better anyway
and the guy's name is still michael
morbius in it and nobody in the movie is
like oh
it's you
you're the guy that's the vampire
jared leto how about the fact that he's
in the worst marvel movie and the worst
dc movie
and the guy just kills it at acting also
when he's not in one of those movies
right like he'll just be in dallas
buyer's club and you're like okay hand
them the oscars and then when he tries
to do [ __ ] morbius you know hey
marvel stop stop i get it but moon
knight
and then people dude there's like
[ __ ] 17 people that are like [ __ ]
yeah dude finally my favorite one moon
knight
this is gonna tank two for disney plus
with the [ __ ] guy from whatever dune
is in it
dude moon knight
change their [ __ ] name dr michael
morbius dude you know imagine you went
to go see a doctor and his name was dr
michael morbius
you'd be like is anyone else in your
practice
what
nothing
you're talking about no well
so
one fire said i thought you're talking
to me for a second i mean so [ __ ]
this is good i make it like we're family
like we're talking like we're having a
conversation i guess i do you know
i am talking to you i'm talking to
everyone right and we're all family i
guess we have to talk about this i
didn't want it because it's been so long
i recorded my [ __ ] podcast
two hours before the oscars
and then that was that week's podcast
and then
and then will smith decided to [ __ ]
[ __ ] slap chris rock
and i was like ah [ __ ]
well i guess i'm late on this and my
views will suffer but still
i've gotta [ __ ] talk about this
because i'm a comedian number one and
number two it was probably the biggest
thing that happened and there's a war in
ukraine
there's the biggest thing that happened
this week and people are getting
slaughtered
in
[ __ ] ukraine so
so all right
if you live under a [ __ ] rock
the oscars happen and chris rock said a
joke about a gi jane joke about jada
pinkett
and will smith smacked him for it [ __ ]
slapped him for it
in the oscars i know you know this right
i'm just saying it because i have to say
it so
how about
first of all
how about let's start with this
why are
how come the oscars
have become
a roast-a-thon
this is the oscars
this is this is the oscars this is the
most prestigious night now of course
sucks donkey balls
now of course it's a bunch of actors who
played stupid parts that are just going
like this all night
now of course the oscars for [ __ ]
of course the oscars are [ __ ]
absolutely ridiculous and full of a
bunch of actors going like this
but it's the most prestigious night any
what do we know if we listen to this
podcast anything prestigious [ __ ]
sucks right
because prestige is nothing it's fake
it's uh pretentious it's a fallacy it's
just a bunch of people going like this
so everyone dresses in their [ __ ]
either nice tuxes or most stupid [ __ ]
outfits of all time right
goes to the oscars
and
they they it's the most prestigious
night so if it's the most prestigious
night then have it be the most
prestigious nice night and by that i
mean why is it a [ __ ] roast-a-thon
it's become a roast-a-thon because you
know i think that they think oh we get
comedians to save the day because the
oscars absolutely [ __ ] suck donkey
balls we need we need for some we need
somebody like ricky gervais at least
we'll be funny but why is it a
roast-a-thon so ricky rodriguez goes on
and shits on the oscars and everybody
and okay and i love ricky gervais all
right and i love a lot of these
comedians but it's become a [ __ ]
roast-a-thon where everyone is just
on making fun of people who do
just have it be the [ __ ] night it is
hey guys
you know what it's it's a it's boring
it's like a wedding ceremony it's
supposed to be boring you're supposed to
have people not watch it because it
[ __ ] sucks
the reason why the views are going down
for the oscars is because everyone's
figuring out what the [ __ ] it is boring
a bunch of actors going like this
and absolutely [ __ ]
it's not supposed to be tel watched
all right it used to be cool before the
internet when william hurt didn't have a
[ __ ] tick tock you know what i mean
it used to be cool when jared leto
wasn't out here on [ __ ] twitter and
now we know everybody
it's not cool anymore to see al pacino
come up and accept an award because
[ __ ]
the goddamn
you know he's a [ __ ] did the daily
news did an arc you can get everyone has
access to everyone at any given moment
nobody gives a [ __ ] anymore about seeing
some actor accept an award and that's
just the stone
cold facts dude
so now it's become this roast-a-thon and
of course
you get these you know comedians up
there that are doing it really good you
got like ricky gervais and chris rock
which is hilarious and then you got
people who are just so [ __ ] corny
with it like amy schumer
and and it's and it's just you're gonna
get [ __ ] it's it's just becoming bad
and unfun to watch and that's fine now
chris rock went up and he made a joke
about um
uh jada pinkett smith about uh doing the
uh the uh gi jane 2 which
first of all is a joke about her being
bald i didn't know she had alopecia and
i heard someone say well it's because
she suffers from alopecia okay let's
cool it on the suffering on the word
suffer okay let's cool it on she
everyone's treating her like she's got
[ __ ] stage five cancer dude her hair
is kind of like gingerly falling out and
by the way i can still see it
okay so she's not suffering that bad
also she's hot as [ __ ] also gi jane was
hot as [ __ ] dude
you'd be lucky if you had a night with
gi jane right gi jane was [ __ ] so
sexy and she shaved her head because she
was in the army
so that's not even a dish
chris rock said gi jane 2 i'm waiting
for you jada pinkett smith it was fine
did chris rock cross the line you know
what if he knew she had alopecia yeah
maybe he did cross the line and guess
what that's
good
because that's what a [ __ ] comedian's
job is to cross the [ __ ] line
how do you know where it is
if you don't cross it every now and then
so whoopsie daisy
so good job chris rock on crossing the
line you did what a comedian should do
now will smith sitting in the front row
laughs at the joke looks over to jada
smith she rolls her eyes then will smith
goes oh she's upset i gotta do something
about it
eh
sir
[ __ ]
right
because you were fine with it she rolled
her eyes and now he gets up and he's a i
gotta be a man about this
walks up to chris rock
chris rock is like oh with his hands
behind his back chris rock is [ __ ]
140 pounds wet
and
will smith played muhammad ali so you
know he's got some [ __ ] a little bit
of technique and also because actors are
so annoying about how they play the
[ __ ] you got you know
like you got to be the [ __ ] guy in
the movie otherwise it's not right like
actors jobs are so easy that they're
like well i'll just be muhammad ali for
[ __ ] nine weeks and i'll learn how to
box and like you know i mean maybe
you're muhammad ali but i had an actor
in that [ __ ] i had a buddy that was
acting in that show the pacific
that was like they made him go to army
boot camp for [ __ ] out in the
wilderness for like
two months and it's like
you just got one line in the movie and
you don't need to [ __ ] rough it
in vietnam for [ __ ] two months right
so
so now will smith comes up and is this
is the biggest [ __ ] part is he's
smiling the whole time and he's being
like hey i'm gonna [ __ ] do something
and then chris rock hands behind his
back
will smith walks up to him
and smacks him in the [ __ ] face
and then walks back to his seat
saunter back to his seat now
only wrong that's only wrong anyone out
here that's saying like well the man
defended his wife [ __ ] that you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude first of all
whatever happened to women can stand for
themselves women empowerment [ __ ] all
that jada shoulda went up and smacked
him if she wanted but the fact that will
smith did that and you think that that's
what a woman needs you're a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] okay
will smith did that it was only wrong he
also did it in the most prestigious
night of his career which was only wrong
and here's the other thing
where was security
he thought he could get away with it or
he didn't know or he was just blind with
anger he still went up and did it
where's [ __ ] security all right
where's security
run and tackle them here's the other
thing dude chris rock had how many i'll
tell you what i know chris rock barely i
know chris rock barely i've had one or
two conversations with him
if i saw someone doing that to him i
would have [ __ ] ran up and helped out
period i don't give a [ __ ] if it was the
oscars or not i would have ran up and
[ __ ] i would have done some [ __ ] i
swear to god and i know a lot of people
are probably out there rolling their
eyes there's no [ __ ] way if i've only
had good experiences with somebody who
is by the way a comedian
that i wouldn't have done something
about it maybe if it was joe rogan or
brendan shaw i would have [ __ ] let it
fly because they could handle themselves
but chris rock dude [ __ ] all that where
the [ __ ] was everybody
that's the thing what nobody's talking
about this where the [ __ ] was everybody
remove will smith because that was
[ __ ] he assaulted him
and remove him from the [ __ ] pla and
then this is how fake hollywood is dude
he won the award what's his fine he won
the awards fair and square he went up
gave a speech about how it is important
it is to protect his family and then
everyone get well some people gave him a
standing ovation
bro what all those people off my list
all those people off crystal leah's list
i know it doesn't matter to you but
guess what matters to me and i'm me so
that's great
you're off my list dude
then it [ __ ] cuts back afterwards to
amy schumer who is chris rock's friend
and she says did anything happen during
the break dude say [ __ ]
say [ __ ] you outsmoking woman say [ __ ]
that's your friend
oh because you're involved in hollywood
you don't say [ __ ]
oh because you're then how outspoken are
you that's assault say [ __ ]
this is something really that happened
that's on tv ladies and gentlemen
we got him say [ __ ] you're so powerful
but you don't say [ __ ] because you want
your deals with hulu to be okay say [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's [ __ ] you want to dance around
that hollywood game they come for you
dude
you don't say [ __ ] about your friend you
watched your friend get smacked by
muhammad ali you don't say [ __ ]
and the night just keeps going [ __ ] that
dude [ __ ] that any one of my friends get
spacked by anybody guess what my friend
gets smacked by somebody who could beat
the [ __ ] out of me if the rock went up
there i'm going up and i'm getting
smacked too [ __ ] i swear to god
too watch it happen
well i guess we're both getting beat up
that's me ah [ __ ] here we go i'll go
face first and just get smacked get it
over with but dude there's no way i'm
letting somebody who i've only had good
experience with deal with that [ __ ] by
themselves [ __ ] the oscars dude [ __ ]
that and [ __ ] those
dude it was it made me so i couldn't
stop thinking about this [ __ ] for four
days i thought about this [ __ ]
i met will smith too he seems like a
nice guy and you know here's the other
thing dude he's just going through some
[ __ ] obviously and i don't know what
he's going through but only he does and
only jada does right
so everyone and now of course will smith
made it worse for himself about the
[ __ ] jokes about his wife and the
jokes about him and how he's a cuck
which he's [ __ ] not you know or he is
and who gives you [ __ ] but like the
internet is just going nuts over it and
i feel bad for will smith too now
because dude everyone doesn't know the
situation and yes what happened was
awful and will smith i'm sure he feels
bad about it because he's not a
sociopath but this was the moment where
he broke
this is the moment where he broke
you can't keep up
like dude i don't know how because i
don't cause will smith is in the
sociopath but like i think like guys
like the rock are just like associate
like i don't know how you
maintain that i don't know how you keep
that up and now he's got a zoa energy
drinking [ __ ] and he's just like okay i
drink tequila too here let's like i
don't know how you keep that energy hey
isn't it enough isn't a hundred million
dollars enough i don't know what the
[ __ ] energy is that you keep that you
need to keep doing this but like i break
dude
i'm i'm i'm one one millionth of a fame
level that will smith is and this [ __ ]
gets to me dude
people say [ __ ] about me i go i go i go
into hiding you know but will smith
every [ __ ] day of his life he can't
go out of his apartment he apartment he
can't go out of one of his 90 houses he
can't do his [ __ ] and then he this is
the moment he broke it he did it on the
world stage literally and did it the
most prestigious night and it was
[ __ ] and it was shitty and it was
and it then it's [ __ ] up and there's
no nothing good about it except for no
there's nothing good about it except for
maybe he could learn from the situation
chris rock handled it like a [ __ ] pro
and i thought that that was amazing and
those are my thoughts on it man you know
and i don't know if it was funny or not
but i don't give a [ __ ] that's how i
feel about it and i just cannot [ __ ]
believe amy schumer didn't say [ __ ]
about that like you're done with me as a
as a like if you're my friend and that
happens i'm done dude done
huh
he's gotta [ __ ] live that the only
person who made sense about to talk
about is jim carrey when he said this
[ __ ] on the thing
it's like
a chris rock couldn't handle it better
yeah i don't want to press charges i
don't want to sue you know it is what it
is and now that's all that anyone is
talking about and it took the whole
night away from everyone it even took
the whole night away from will smith he
won the [ __ ] oscar it took his whole
night away from it it's all anyone
doesn't want to talk about it so anyone
is ever going to talk about in the
during that oscars and there were
probably good shitty movies that won
morbius should have [ __ ] cleaned up
that night is what i do know
and the award for
best
worst name
michael oh i'm sorry morbius michael
morbius and morbius
it's him it was him the whole time
everyone should have known when they met
him
even when he was his
alter ego
my because his name is michael morbius
jared little gets up there with a
[ __ ] bright green trash bag on and a
[ __ ]
mailman hat
hey nothing to see here i thank you for
the award
just look into my steel blue eyes
yeah
yeah
um the the fact that logan paul
uh
bought this six million dollar
rare pikachu card and where by by the
way the the this the words rare pikachu
card you know who cares how rare it is
but it's a thing and it's a collector's
item and by the way he looked badass on
the [ __ ] ww whatever it is and now i
don't know
but uh he paid six million dollars on a
very rare pokemon card and then wore
that card during his wrestlemania 38
years of why because the internet
inspectors have destroyed reality yeah
it's true this is on kodakku.com but 27
year old paul
first teased his pokemon card accessory
on april 2nd when he revealed he's
planning to wear the very rare so he
wore it in wrestlemania 38 a six million
dollars dude get it how do you not how
do you not be robbed right there's
people out there getting robbed in
beverly hills nobody [ __ ] robbed this
[ __ ] off his neck this is insane most of
the special pokemon card in the world
right now and partially is because he
and he paid for it like if he tried to
resell it right now there's no way he
could get [ __ ] six million dollars
for it and he did it to be in the
headlines but my question is
uh
how much money two things it's twofold
how much money does logan paul have and
then also how much money do you have to
have to spend six million dollars on a
[ __ ] pikachu card
cause like
if you have a hundred million dollars
spending six of it on a pikachu card is
a [ __ ]
horrible idea
so if you have 200 million dollars
and you spend six million dollars on a
pikachu card that's a horrible idea
if you have three now if you have three
million dollars
and you want to spend six million
dollars on a pikachu card
that is a
horrible idea
so at what point does it become not a
horrible idea now let's not pretend that
logan paul makes the best decisions but
he's a great guy and he makes good
decisions business-wise i know him i
love the dude right
and
you know he makes great decisions
business-wise
right that prime energy drink
but
he
made this decision which seems like a
bad decision but also probably doesn't
matter but my point is how much money
does he have and then how much money do
you have to have
half a billion
he does he doesn't have half a billion
but if you had half a billion
then okay maybe six million on a picture
card if you really love pokemons right
would you say half of
this is insane to me
he just want to be in the gizz book of
records how much is that
worth how much is the pr of buying this
card worth is what i want to know not
six million certainly
and then how much can you sell it for so
he's gonna take a hit when he tries to
sell it or maybe he won't try to sell it
but he could always sell it right he
could always sell it if he wanted to
well i forgot to talk about this tweet
about what happened when the [ __ ]
will smith thing happened this was the
best one i thought this was a joke when
i first saw it is by sophie hagan who's
uh has no brain i guess but like um so
she she is yeah it's a woman so she
writes i think will smith should this is
so great man everyone making everything
about everything that it's not is just
so great right everyone makes everything
about everything that it's not that's
what the internet does but this woman
writes i don't know who she is she got a
blue check she's probably a sweet lady
i'm just making fun of you okay um she
says i think that will smith [ __ ] and
then hyphen wait looks at hands with
aster surrounded oh hang on i'm quite
white so maybe i don't need to have an
opinion on what a black man did to
another black man because of what he
said about his black wife maybe i should
just shut up and listen hey
no
no first of all what you did isn't going
to stop anyone from talking it's just
going to exacerbate and uh you
exasperated the situation you made white
people look dumber than even talking
about
congratulations dude you can talk about
anything you want it's how the internet
works also this has nothing to do with
race a guy hit a guy and it was bad
was he black k was the other guy black k
was the wife black k
a guy hit another guy and it was bad
dude people making everything about
everything that it's not is hilarious
i don't i think that will like to think
that you're a hero in this situation for
black people because you tweet something
like hey if you're white you shouldn't
chime in on how do black people give a
[ __ ] about not chiming in also hey
you're chiming in
don't talk about it don't not
[ __ ] god you know it's like
you don't know the situation period so
you might as well either chime in or not
it has nothing to do with the fact that
you have white hands
so dumb dude
hey
will smith should hold on a second i've
actually never worn a suit myself and
they're both dressed in suits
chex dress checks body hmm wearing a
frilly dress maybe i should shut up and
listen
a man was protecting his family
let me check around hmm czech
surroundings no kids but i'm at home not
a mom i don't have kids those men have
kids
who am i to tell a man who has a family
how to react on a joke about his family
hmm maybe i should just shut up and
listen
i mean how far does it extend dude
race wasn't an issue here also it was
hilarious that the first
um
[Music]
the first
[Music]
time that it was presented by like a
black
person organization the oscars that this
happened
black lives matter real questions this
came out
i hate that joke
hey they've been real quiet since
that's it for youtube uh if you want to
catch the rest of the show the uncut
ad free episode uh and all that free
episodes uh go to
patreon.comcrystalia and you can get the
extra episode there's like 13 episodes
or something 12 or 13 episodes now that
aren't available except for here on
except for on patreon and uh also every
month there's a one patreon episode that
we don't do for youtube so uh and
there's another there's other stuff too
like behind the scenes stuff for the
with chris videos and also uh the uh
segment um that we do called review mode
so yeah uh have at it
patreon.com thanks
[Music]
you